très élégant quoique rasé avec une
biscotte
l'ogc nice aussi fier version il était
une fois en amérique en ce chrono time
in america
si vous préférez le roi lion tous les
goûts sont dans la nature on ne rit pas
de toute manière ces deux hommes ne font
qu'un ils sont de la même trempe de la
même veine j'ai l'impression d'un jeu d
y aller ne trouveront pas leur première
rencontre puisque c'est comme ça je m'en
vais et djallit venus d'argentine au
mitard et eve est invité à partager des
choses des allocs et j'ai voulu faire de
votre syndicat international des joueurs
moi je prends le risque que la condition
que toi tu sois là et que tu es que tu
verras que tu gères tu que tu gères à
tout le monde de quoi qui que tu sois le
président de tout ça parce que j'ai un
profond respect pour toi une profonde
confiance à fond de confiance en toi
c'est l'histoire de deux hommes qui
n'ont pas la langue de bois
le président de la fédération
internationale joue seulement tout
interpol uniquement au water polo et le
secrétaire général blatter au chantage
joueur il est ridicule
c'est l'histoire de deux hommes qui
rejette toute forme de soumission
même si ça semble être des banalités il
était important de le dire est important
de se battre pour que le football
revient au footballeur et pour que le
business ne bouffe pas ce qui a été
notre rêve c'est l'histoire de deux
hommes pour qui les valeurs sportives
ont encore un sens
à merlieux mouche moi ça fait beaucoup
de mal c'est de voir une épreuve jouée
par ordinateur c'est quelque chose que
je n'arrive pas à comprendre une épreuve
jouée par ordinateur quand ils disent at
elle joue avec en tête l autre avec tel
à table déjà avant le début de la partie
l'histoire de deux hommes qui parlent
vrai du coup les compliments lorsqu'il
sont prononcés prend ici toute leur
dimension
il a fait ce qu'il fallait sur un
terrain et je suis ce nombre que je
respecte comme j'ai comme je respecte
mon père et mes frères ma mère des
hommes qui malgré tous les moments
exceptionnels de leur existence mais
également tous les coups bas dont ils
ont été les victimes n'ont pas fermé
leur queue
oui décidément tant qu'il y aura des
hommes
[Musique]